talk of an october's surprise a
game-changing event that comes right
before a u.s election has been pretty
common in the united states for the past
several decades
well this year's october surprise is
here
it came in the form of a positive
covid19
test for donald trump and the first lady
the nation is in shock
the white house knew that hope hicks had
tested positive and the president
had been in close contact with her yet
he proceeded to still travel yesterday
for his fundraiser he is not able to
fully perform
his his duties as commander-in-chief we
were seeing people
without masks regularly we were seeing
people uh stopping just
not socially distancing they stopped
taking temperatures for people who were
regular
visitors to the white house we have seen
that it has ended up in the worst case
scenario
for the white house donald trump got
tested after it was confirmed that his
staffer hope hicks had been
infected the results came in and it was
pretty clear at that point
that the campaign is now curving in a
new direction now let's not forget that
donald trump actually
downplayed the covet 19 threat and even
mocked joe biden for being more cautious
looks like by april you know in theory
when it gets a little warmer it
miraculously goes away hope that's true
we have it very much under control
right here the united states is lowest
in numerous categories
uh we're lower than the world they
wanted me to come out and scream
people are dying with that no no
we did it just the right way now we're
weeks away from a vaccine
we're doing therapeutics already fewer
people are dying when they get sick
far fewer people are dying we've done a
great job
democrats jumped on donald trump's
diagnosis to once again
call him out for mishandling the crisis
going into crowds
unmasked and all the rest was sort of a
brazen invitation
for something like this to happen though
they have not done so in the past
the administration must now follow the
science and all recommended health
protocols
in order to not put additional people at
risk and they must be completely
transparent some of the reactions have
gotten rather
ugly it's been against my moral identity
to tweet this for the past four years
but
i hope he dies the second scheduled
debate
intended for the discussion of foreign
policy remains up in the air
even if donald trump doesn't get too
badly sick he'll still be under
quarantine
now let us not forget that donald trump
is 74 years old and
overweight he's in a high risk group for
whom covid can be lethal
no one really trusts the information
coming out of the white house
he we have no idea how sick he is he's
74 years old he's overweight
he's in a high risk group and he may
become
severely ill if he goes into intensive
care the way boris johnson did
in april that could lead to a
constitutional question as to who
actually will run the white house
and the constitutional mechanism is
extremely slow
extremely inefficient and
maybe faulty in design it's hard to
believe nancy pelosi taking over the
white house but
that's what the uh the law says so it
may very well happen
the situation is unprecedented the u.s
is entering to a period of
extreme turmoil things were already
turbulent enough as they were
now they are doubly severe over a dozen
campaign rallies have now been canceled
so
how will the public react will there be
sympathy for donald trump now that he's
been infected
or will this be seen as further
confirmation of the democrats argument
that he lacks clear
judgment only the voters can answer that
question caleb maupin
rt new york